greetings Robert Spencer here from Jihad
watch coming to you from the land of the
free and the home of the brave where
Barack Obama is busy strong arming the
Catholic Church into discarding its
Faith while while apologizing abjectly
to the government and people of
Afghanistan for not abiding by Islamic
law Provisions regarding the treatment
of the Quran and so I congratulate you
all in the Q Society for a year of hard
work you have succeeded to a tremendous
degree in putting the issue of
islamization on the map in Australia and
for that you are all to be hardly
commended uh remember don't be
intimidated or disheartened there is a
long road ahead but we have the truth on
our side and so the enemy will begin to
attack more and more fiercely the more
clearly and the more forthrightly we are
telling the truth so that is an
indication not of failure but of your
success remember also we are fighting
against the enemies of Freedom we are
fighting against small group of Islamic
supremacists who are intent upon
changing our governments and societies
and infringing upon the freedom of
speech the freedom of conscience the
issue of equality of rights for women
for equality of Rights for non-muslims
and so on and we are not fighting
against any Muslim who in Australia or
in the United States of America or in
Europe wants to come and abide by the
laws of the land and is happy to be free
of sharia regimes we are fighting for
Freedom we are fighting for decent
government and decent society and we
have nothing to apologize for at the
same time I would also like to alert you
to the establishment of a new
International Coalition stop
islamization of Nations and we are
holding our first conference this
September in New York City and I hope
that uh we will see an Australian
representative or two there I'd also
like to congratulate you for the uh
opening of the Q Society branch in
Adelaide
uh I hear that Adelaide has some
excellent Wineries and so uh am hoping
to be able to come back in the coming
year and visit your group in Adelaide
and uh sample some of the local product
uh and also I'd like to alert you
finally to the uh imminent publication
on April 23rd of my new book did
Muhammad exist an inquiry into Islam's
obscure Origins which is sure to receive
accolades from Pakistan Iran and
worldwide thank you very much and I hope
to see you again soon